hi guys I'm Marcus mustard I'm chesty
and I am English Leo I named Ronnie
Stanley we're gonna pick our all-time
favorite Chiefs at 49ers squad
[Music]
I'm talking about man Marcus over here
we got to go with the speedster right
here Tyreke oh yeah by you comparing to
like who's the fastest guy you would say
this game for Salah it's a guy called
Troy over the Wolves why is he so cheap
though I don't know we taking it so we
need a quarterback now so I'm thinking
Pat mahomes for $3 they play on the same
team that's all right
got 11 more dollars to work with all
right so we need a big guy than amount
yeah oh you in there we got a we got to
choose from Richard Sherman is pretty
good I mean playing on a Hall of Fame
level yeah there's only for $2 he's in
the Super Bowl right now yeah that's
Portman man oh man so right now we have
nine dollars to work with more players
but in the big books big bucks no big
books it's been five of them one I'm
falling over it's a good idea it's a
good idea so Derrick Thomas linebacker I
don't think you go wrong with Derrick
Thomas you know it's a nice move so now
we need a running back I'll be right
back we have Roger Craig and that's
you're not settling there so we just put
on them
yeah all right quickly some nice it's a
nice board our team our first pick we we
picked I retail for a dollar we just
thought that was a great partner for us
had a position where it's it's really
hard to guard this guy he's always on
attack now I'm gonna feel like this guy
Marty is always attacking always causing
problems for defenders next pick was a
quarterback time I Holmes
they already play on the same team
Richard Sherman we thought we picked him
up for a good deal for only $2 and you
know he's a future Hall of Fame
quarterback
just his his brain is a very smart
player you know how some are players
they could change the game Derek Thomas
and Roger Craig and we think those guys
are really going to be great leaders you
know though you really need those guys
to set the standard present for the team
obviously you can have a good
individuals but if you don't gel
together and I'm really improve as a
team then you know that you can have a
team with less talent but they can be so
then that's was interested in sports hi
my name is Marcus Rochefort my name is
Ronnie Stanley and we just finished
building our squad
[Music]